hola como estas donde esta el Maria
porfavor no a bow feat a soos vacas
jirafa Naranjo siete Bono's mariachi
tengo muchas enchiladas deja de hablar
me tacos soy caballo as you can see I
was just speaking Spanish there I am
fluent in Spanish I that's why in case
you didn't notice I was speaking Spanish
I can speak Spanish and did I mention
that I speak Spanish I just want to be
sure that you caught the whole bit where
I was speaking Spanish just just right
there pretty pretty impressive I did not
make it a big deal of it or anything but
it's a you know pretty impressive that I
can speak two languages we discovered
last night that a number of Democratic
presidential candidates speak Spanish
and they were eager to show off the fact
that they speak Spanish especially
better or wark who broke into it
randomly in the first question creating
one of the most hilarious and
uncomfortable moments of the night for
me one of the most hilarious and
uncomfortable moments that I've seen in
a debate in a long time
and we will revisit that moment in a
moment and a few other moments as well
but first let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project finding the right freelancer can
be time-consuming and frustrating also
expensive a lot of questions a lot of
unknowns like how much will it cost to
hire a freelancer where you're gonna
find the talent how can you be sure
they'll deliver what is the meaning of
life
well fiber can help you answer those
questions except for the last one I
guess that's more your kind of on your
own with that thanks to fiber finding
the right freelancer doesn't have to be
a struggle I've talked to several people
have used fiber and they've all raved
about how simple it is I'll straight
forward just makes the whole process
easier there's no there's no guesswork
nothing to worry about
here's how it works fibers marketplace
connects businesses with freelancers who
offer hundreds of digital services
including graphic design copywriting web
programming film editing and much more
can find what you're looking for
instantly by searching based on they
break it down into categories and based
on service delivery time price reviews
much more take five and check-out
fiverr.com and you will receive 10% off
your first order just by using my code
Walsh it's so easy don't waste any more
time and and and get the service that
you deserve by going to fiverr.com
that's f IV e to ours dot-com fi ve are
our comm and code Walsh again that's
fiverr.com code Walsh alright so let's
talk about the Democratic debates for
some reason we're going to talk about it
I these debates of course don't really
matter that much because nothing matters
anymore in general and also because the
news cycle moves so quickly that nobody
remembers anything for more than half a
day at most especially early early on
like this when there are 67 people in
the field we're still it feels like it's
three three hundred years away from the
actual election taking place it's no
one's gonna buy by the time you go to
vote but time everyone goes to vote in
2020 no one's gonna remember anything
that happened today or last night but
mainly the issue is simply that we live
in a culture where everyone has the
memory of fruit flies so do you remember
even what was the big story the big news
story we were all talking about two
weeks ago or last week I don't remember
and I was on this show talking whatever
it was I have no idea and it I get
people sometimes will will they'll
discover the show they'll go back and
they'll watch the old ones and catch up
and they'll send me emails about some of
the older shows when I say older shows I
mean sometimes like shows that I did
three days ago and I appreciate that
they're doing then they're sending
emails but they're responding to
discussions we had and I have no memory
of like what we talked about that really
so I get to relive it which is kind of
exciting and that's how it is for
everyone everything in vaporators
replaced by by new information we're
consuming so so much information there's
so much going on
that we have to shove out the old
information and replace it with a new
every day and there's this recharging
process that takes place where we
remember nothing at the end and then you
add in the fact that 99% of what you
hear at a debate is pre-planned canned
staged phony us speaking in sound bytes
nobody's even attempting to offer
anything that approaches or resembles an
authentic human thought or opinion there
are very few actual back-and-forth Scone
on the one thing that rarely happens at
a modern debate is debate you'll see a
little bit of that there will be a few
moments where the people start breaking
into actual debate where they're
actually like arguing with each other
and making points back and forth to each
other but then what always happens is
the moderator steps in and says hey hey
hey we're not gonna have any of that
debating at this debate okay or follow
the rules now let's return to my boring
and irrelevant questions and and that's
we do we move back to the Q&A thing and
then each candidate gets a chance to
speak in talking points again an actual
debate would be something like okay
here's the topic here are a few points
or things to grapple with go ahead have
at it and and then the candidates talk
to each other that's what a real debate
would be everyone people like to mention
what's considered one of the great
American political baits of all time the
lincoln-douglas debate of 1858 and those
of course were we're not televised
because most families back then didn't
have TVs it's a little historical nugget
for you but you can go and you can read
the transcripts the the back-and-forth
that took place at this debate and it's
considered a great debate for a reason
because there are it's an actual debate
the two men are going back and forth
making long sort of eloquence in depth
points to each other and at
doesn't have anymore with that said now
that I've explained why it doesn't
matter and it's totally pointless we're
good we're going to take a look at some
of the memorable moments memorable
moments by that I mean moments that
you'll remember until dinner time and
then forget so let's do that will be we
begin with robert francis O'Rourke
otherwise known by his stage name Beto
who was once considered a star in the
Democratic Party and now he's just kind
of this sad and boring little guy who
does stuff like this to get attention
watch this what we've just been
discussing and talking about is how much
fundamental change to the economy is
desirable and how much is actually
doable in that vein some Democrats want
a marginal individual tax rate of 70% on
the very highest earners those making
more than ten million dollars a year
would you support that and if not what
would your top individual rate be this
economy has got to work for everyone and
right now we know that it isn't and it's
going to take all of us coming together
to make sure that it does necesitamos
incluir cada persona en el éxito de este
po no Meah pero si quiere most hacer ESO
necesitamos in cuy cada persona in
nuestro democracia cara votar caca de
votante necesitamos la representación de
cada vez necesito mas escuchar okay now
of course NBC offers subtitles for
Spanish speakers so that stunt was just
that it was a stunt and it made even
less sense when you consider that he
didn't continue it constantly throughout
the entire debate now when he did that
with his first answer and when he did
that I thought is he gonna do this for
every question but you kind of have to
do it for if you're gonna do it once
then don't you have to do it for every
question it doesn't make any sense to
only do it once or twice so but that's
what enough he did it only a couple of
times which which makes it even more
bizarre so for instance Beto did not he
gave his answer on climate change where
he explained like all the others did
that we're all gonna drown and die
anytime now but he didn't give that in
Spanish he only gave it at English so
what does he it does he not care if
Hispanic people drown when the polarized
caps melt is that what he's trying to
say he's basically say to the Spanish
speakers hey you guys don't need to hear
this part all right I mean like the rest
of us you know we're gonna we got to
build an arc here because it's gonna be
flooding now you guys don't need hear
this stuff don't oh don't worry about it
don't worry doesn't concern you uh see
that's what if if you if you're
pretending that you have to speak in
Spanish also so that they understand
what you're saying
then it because then it's you you have
to stick with it you can't only do it
once that's the problem I think the most
telling part and then there was a Cory
Booker and Julian Castro they also broke
it in Spanish at a couple different
points and Booker was asked about it
after the debate on NBC have asked you
know how he felt about O'Rourke speaking
Spanish and then Booker said hey well
you know he threw down the gauntlet and
and me and Castro we knew that we you
know we had to bring it also so what
he's admitting is that he's admitting
that it was a stunt he was admitting
that it was just a dumb competition
there was nothing sincere about it he
was using the Spanish language as a
stunt he admitted that which I don't
know if I was a Spanish speaker I would
not appreciate that
now I think the most telling part of the
debate happened maybe about midway
through and up until this point a few of
the candidates had thrown in some lines
about killing babies just to get a quick
applause line you know there was one
point one of the candidates I don't
remember who was making a point had
nothing to do with abortion and then he
noticed he was losing the crowd people
were kind of their eyes were glossing
over and so we threw in a quick line
about hey yeah we need to kill babies he
didn't say that exactly but in essence
that's what he said and then it got the
crowd perked up and they started up
killing babies yeah oh yes this is what
the modern Democratic Party has become
they that but they did break into a
full-on competition to see who supports
killing the babies the most and it was
established that none of them want any
restrictions of any kind on the practice
and in fact they all want abortion for
free so here they are going back and
forth on that
should not be an option in the United
States of America for any insurance
company to deny woman coverage for their
exercise of their right of choice I am
the only candidate here who has passed a
law protecting a woman's right a
reproductive health and health insurance
and I'm the only candidate who has
passed a public option and I respect
everybody's goals and plans here but we
do have one candidate that's actually
advanced the ball and we got to have
access for everyone I just want to say
there's three women up here that have
fought pretty hard for a woman's right
to choose
senator why would you put limits on any
limits on abortion I would make certain
that every woman has access to the full
range of reproductive health care
services and that includes birth control
it includes abortion it includes
everything for a woman it's not enough
for us to expect the courts to protect
us 47 years ago Roe vs. Wade was decided
and we've all looked to the courts all
that time as state after state has
undermined Roe has put in exceptions has
come right up to the edge of taking away
protection as I've senator we now have
an America where most people support Roe
vs. Wade we need to make that thank you
this again is what the modern Democratic
Party has become this is what it's been
for many years now it is a party utterly
obsessed with abortion a party unmoor
unattached unmoored disconnected from
any notion of basic morality or human
decency there isn't even a debate
anymore about anything related to
abortion in a democratic party that they
aren't talking about win personhood
begins or about win abortion is
acceptable about fetal pain or or
whatever they aren't talking about any
of that they don't care it's just
abortion for everyone at any point for
free that's that's where they are there
is an
there cannot be any nuance there cannot
be any equivocation or reservation or
moderation just everyone is on the
abortion train and even that isn't
extreme enough so abortion for all women
for any reason at any point for free you
would think well that's as extreme and
as absolute as it gets but not so fast
Castro he took it a step further what
this one does for you all of you on
stage support a woman's right to an
abortion you all support some version of
a government health care option would
your plan cover abortion mr. secretary
yes it would I don't believe only in
reproductive freedom I believe in
reproductive justice what that means is
that just because a woman or let's also
not forget someone in the trans
community a trans female is poor doesn't
mean they shouldn't have the right to
exercise that right to choose and so I
absolutely would cover the right to have
an abortion more than he could he could
barely say that with a straight face if
you watched him him say that he could
barely get it out because he knows that
what he just said is nonsensical we need
to give abortion rights to trans females
in other words men okay a trans woman is
a man a biological man and this grown
adult this somehow successful and
prominent relatively speaking political
figure just claims on national TV that
biological men can get pregnant and he
of course knows this is nonsense cousin
actually doesn't actually think that
there's the reason why if you go back to
the 2008 Democratic presidential debate
or any any debate before that none of
these people were talking about trans
and you know men getting pregnant nobody
was talking about that nobody was
because because they are
it wasn't a question then now they're
talking about it even though they've all
lived if you're looking at a Democratic
presidential candidate who's pretending
to take this trans stuff seriously
pretending to actually believe that a
biological man can be a woman and even
get pregnant well these are these are
grown adults most of them are much older
so they have lived most of them 40 or 50
years never talking about this never
bringing it up and then all of a sudden
in the last few years it's oh yeah I
don't know I by well I believe this all
along that I believed all along that
biological sex is basically a myth you
never would have guessed it because I
never said it and I spoke and behaved as
if I just believed that there are only
men and women but I believe that all
along oh yeah now this is just Craven
opportunism Castro saying something that
he knows is scientifically illiterate
insane absurd but he's saying it
anywhere anyway and it's an applause
line for Democrats now if we lived in a
sane country and if we live in a sane
country then Castro's political career
would be over after he just stood on
national TV and claimed that men can get
pregnant it would be over he would be
the laughingstock of the country and
that would be it for him but instead
it's an applause line and I bet you that
his polls pull his poll numbers go up
today go from you know 1% to 3 or
something
but you know what okay I agree actually
I'm going to agree with Castro yes
let's give abortion rights to men
because if if if men are pregnant that's
not a baby in there I can tell you that
if you're a man if you're an actual
biological man and you're pregnant then
yes you should get an abortion because
that's not a baby that's your this is
either a scene from alien or you have a
tapeworm in fence the infestation either
way yes you
go and kill whatever it is cuz it ain't
a baby that's for sure
or if we're talking about abortion
rights for men if you mean by that that
men should have a say in the fate of
their children then I agree with that
also alright but I'm you know what I'm
glad as I was watching the debate I was
glad that this was happening I'm glad
that they put this on display I'm glad
that the Democrats put their insanity on
display for everyone to see so that the
average Joe Schmo sitting at home you
know the blue-collar worker in Minnesota
that you know that those just that
random hypothetical person that people
that the candidates and debates like to
always bring up I'm looking for policies
that are going to positively affect the
nurse in Iowa or the or the or the lunch
lady in Ohio it always just happening
they just happen to choose the swing
states for the for their hypothetical
anecdotal people anyway if you but if
you are someone like that watching at
home and you're not very normally very
politically invested or aware I'm glad
that you got a chance to see that this
is what the Democratic Party is they're
fighting over who wants to kill babies
the most and they're claiming that men
get pregnant that's what the Democratic
Party is if you're seeing that in your
thinking what this is what they are is
it this has got to be some kind of fluke
no it's not a fluke this is what they
are and so you decide if you want to
have anything to do with these people or
not all right a couple other things I
thought this was interesting watch this
many plans free college free child care
government health care cancellation of
student debt new taxes new regulations
the breakup of major corporations but
this comes at a time when 71% of
Americans say the economy is doing well
including 60% of Democrats what do you
say to those who worry this kind of
significant change could be risky to the
economy so I think of it this way who is
this economy really working for it's
doing great for a thinner and thinner
slice at the top
doing great for giant drug companies
this is not doing great for people are
trying to get a prescription filled it's
doing great for people who want to
invest in private prisons just not for
the African Americans and Latin X whose
families are torn apart whose lives are
destroyed and whose communities are
ruined it's doing great for giant oil
companies that want to drill everywhere
just not for the rest of us who are
watching climate change bear down upon
us
ok that was at the very beginning of the
debate I think I just cut her off there
mid-sentence but
bla bla bla you get it did you catch the
Latina 'kz by the way that's the new
politically correct term because you
can't say Latino anymore because that's
gendered and it excludes females and it
excludes the other of 57 genders so
lateen don't love t necks I think it's
how she pronounced it I thought it was
pronounced latinx that's really how I
all this time I thought I figured
because it's Latin X it's like L atin X
so I thought it was latinx which does
sound a little clunky but look teen X
that sounds like a like an inappropriate
website lateen X that doesn't sound
that's just of course it's a made-up
word and so of course it sounds
completely silly but anyway notice how
she's she was told that she was told by
the moderator to begin the question that
71% of Americans say the economy is
doing well and she responds including
61% of Democrats she responds by
insisting that no actually the economy
is terrible and there was a lot of that
last night where it's the setup to the
question is the economy is doing well no
eggs are terrible trust me they said
things are awful people are hating it
it's people are depressed they're
starving to death no no but they say
those 71 percent say it's oh no no no no
it's terrible it's terrible
is that how the conversation when
they're on the campaign trail if
somebody goes up to if they one of these
candidates goes up to someone sitting at
a diner they're out there how are things
for you other things are doing pretty
well no they're not they're not doing
well for you you are you are in despair
you are crushed
your life is miserable trust me trust me
but this is in order for Elizabeth
Warren's goal is socialism the goal of
all these people of socialism either by
that word or another and in order for
them to pass their socialist policies
they need to convince us that the
economy's is in shambles and it's a
disaster they need for it too and if
it's not actually in shambles like they
wish it was they wish it was I mean they
would love it if the unemployment rate
was 30 percent and people were starving
to death on the streets they would love
that there that's what they would prefer
because of course these people don't
care about human life at all which is
why they can not bat an eye at 60
million human babies being killed so but
because it's not that unfortunately for
them they have to convince us that
that's what it's like so they can then
shove their socialist policies down our
throats and it's all pretty gross
speaking of gross we'll watch one more
clip watch this it's a simple question
what is art what is the biggest threat
to what is who is the geopolitical
threat to the United States just give me
one more to answer congressman Delaney
could you repeat the greatest
geopolitical threat to the United States
right now congressman Delaney
well the biggest geopolitical challenge
is China but the okay geopolitical
threat yes remains nuclear weapons all
right so those are do you know that I
got a different question totally get it
go ahead governor Inslee the biggest
threat to the security the United States
is Donald Trump so that guy and I don't
even know who he is I don't know how
half those people were I haven't I don't
know who that guy is but he's somebody
you're not gonna win he says the biggest
threat to the United States is the
President of the United States now if
Trump had said imagine that Trump had
said in a debate that the biggest threat
to United States is Barack Obama and now
he kind of uses rhetoric like that about
the media saying they're the enemy of
the people and so on but how does the
media how does the Left react when he
says stuff like that there's a is a
dangerous rhetoric it's terrible T
responsible you're gonna get somebody
killed well isn't it that if you say the
biggest threat to the United States is
the president
how do you if there's some crazy wacko
would-be assassin out there how do you
think he's gonna respond to that by the
logic of the left and what they say
about when when Trump calls the what he
his rhetoric and how it's dangerous is
gonna get people killed by that same
logic aren't you potentially getting the
president killed when you say stuff like
that that he's the greatest threat to
the United States how is that not
reckless and irresponsible rhetoric
that's what I don't get
well of course it is but but again it
was a massive applause line so
everything is hypocritical and nobody
cares all right before we continue a
word about about something pretty
awesome let's let's translate let's get
that taste out of our mouth of all that
stupidity and nonsense here's something
awesome big token big token is a new app
that lets you share data about yourself
your interest your habits and then you
get paid for it okay you get paid right
now you already shared an enormous
amount of information about yourself
whether you know it or not whether you
like it or not you're sharing
information and you're not making any
money on it people are making money on
you you're not making money that's not
what this country is about that's not
what what living and free-market
capitalism is about and as long as we
live in a free market which who knows
that might be only only for another two
years
then then you should be able to make the
money off of your own information and
that's where big token comes in here's
how it works first download the app and
sign up for free big token account next
complete actions to earn points actions
include answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and much more then you can
redeem your points for rewards such as
cash and gift cards or you could donate
your earnings to charity if you're a
very generous person and then you can do
that but whatever the case is you choose
what data you share with big token and
then you get paid for you all you can
also get more points for referring
friends and family your data is always
secure with big token and they take it
very seriously they take your privacy
seriously based on the data you choose
to share you'll be placed in the
specific
had groups and brands will buy access to
those ad groups for use in personalized
advertising the best part again to
emphasize you get paid cash money okay
if you want to start earning money for
your for your data go to the App Store
or Google Play
you could search for big token bi gto ke
n that's one word download the app and
sign up make sure to use my referral
code which is matt walsh again search
big token in the App Store Google Play
download the app I've done it's very
easy to do it doesn't take long and then
you're up and running and also use my
referral code matt walsh to sign up
claim your data and get paid all right
ah i want to revisit something from
yesterday because this came up in the
debate a lot and people are still
talking about it and i think there is
there's a more complete story that needs
to be told a more complete story that
when i discussed this issue yesterday i
didn't I didn't know the full story that
I hadn't read it now I do so I want to
go back to this as we talked about
yesterday there's that gut wrenching
photo that's that that really strikes at
the heart of the immigration debate in
this country and the photo went viral it
shows a father and his young daughter
face down on the shore of the Rio Grande
the girl has her arm around the man's
neck and they're both they're both dead
it's horrible devastating heartbreaking
just awful now the left has attempted to
use this image to make the case for open
borders and we're told that somehow this
is Trump's fault it's the Republicans
fault
it's a GOP s fault but the story behind
the if now even if we even if we didn't
know the story behind the image and at
first we didn't all we knew that was
that you had these two people
unfortunately that had died and even
without knowing any of the background
you already know that this isn't the
president's fault the president didn't
do this
if this is some one if this is illegal
immigration we're talking about again
that's not now we could we could talk
about who to blame but there's just no
way to put it on the present now that we
know the full story though it emphasizes
even more that this has nothing to do
with immigration enforcement or if it
does it's about lacks immigration
enforcement and it certainly is not
Trump's fault or the fault of the
Republican Party or whatever so the full
story as reported by The Daily Mail in
New York magazine and others is that
Oscar Alberto Martinez Ramirez and his
daughter
Valeria were swept away but while trying
to cross the Rio Grande into Texas on
Sunday now Oscar had made it across with
his daughter but then he went back to
get his wife and tragically his daughter
was afraid scared young girl thinks less
less than two years old she followed her
daughter her father back into the water
and was then taken by the river he tried
to save her and they both drowned the
Daily Mail describes the circumstances
that led to this family attempting to
traverse a dangerous river on foot now
reading for the Daily Mail now they say
they left El Salvador on April 3rd and
spent two months in a migrant camp in
southern Mexico awaiting news of their
asylum request to the US before they
decided to take a bus to the border on
Sunday to try to speed up their case
when they arrived the consulate was
closed but they also learned they were
far down a list of hundreds of migrants
in line for interviews they decided to
make the crossing illegally rather than
wait a decision that led to their deaths
this was not a family turned coldly away
at the border as it fled violence and
persecution they weren't turned away at
all they simply grew impatient waiting
for the bureaucratic wheels to turn
which I get it that I would be impatient
to but this was not being turned away
indeed family members confirm that the
family was not being persecuted in its
home country this was not really a case
of legitimates
these were not refugees in other words
reading now again says Oscar worked at a
Papa John's pizza restaurant where he
was earning $350 a month they lived off
his way
limiting themselves to $10 a day because
Taniya that's the the wife I believe had
already quit her job as a cashier in a
Chinese restaurant
to care for Valeria their only child
they were not fleeing violence
Tania's mother had since said but were
in desperate search of a life where they
could earn more their plan was to spend
a few years in America to save up money
and then to return to El Salvador and
buy buy or build their own house now
this might explain why their asylum
request was taking so long to process
Ramirez and his family we're looking for
asylum from low-paying fast-food jobs
which is not how the asylum program is
traditionally meant to be used the US
Citizenship and Immigration Services
website defines asylum and this is what
they say asylum is and how it works
refugee status or asylum may be granted
the people who have been persecuted or
fear they will be persecuted on account
of race religion nationality and/or
membership in a particular social group
or political opinion we have stretched
the concept of persecuted on account of
race religion or social group into
meaninglessness if we include those who
are understandably distressed by low
wages this is economic immigration this
is not Asylum if you blame the terrible
deaths of Oscar and Valeria Ramirez on
Trump well then what are you saying
exactly are you arguing that the
president should have personally moved
the Ramirez family to the front of the
Asylum line in front of people who may
actually be fleeing violence and
persecution or else are you saying that
that the asylum system should be that
there should be a general policy and
stated that just grants immediate asylum
to everyone who asks for it no questions
asked
obviously both of those things are
absurd so if you're not advocating for
either of those things then how could
you possibly blame this on Trump it's
not Trump's fault that they were living
in poverty in El Salvador it's and it's
so what what did he do it seems that if
you're looking for someone to blame or
something to blame there are two
systemic problems we complain first the
uses of the asylum system have been
tolerated for so long the people who
shouldn't qualify for asylum still
expect to receive it
I don't blame Ramirez for seeking asylum
he was doing what he thought he needed
to do for his family I might have done
the same thing in his position but we
obviously cannot make somebody a refugee
based on the fact that they're getting
low wages at Papa John's by that logic
then there are a lot of refugees who are
American citizens who could apply for
refugee status because they're working
at Papa John's it just it doesn't work
that way
so requests of that kind should be
denied immediately and loopholes that
encourage or or allow these sorts of
abuses have to be closed second as we
talked about yesterday our border is
porous everybody knows it
Ramirez knew that if you could just make
it across the river which he almost did
and tragically he did not ultimately but
he knew that if he could just do that
he'd probably be home free I think if
the word had gotten out to men like
Ramirez that his chances of making it
across the border were extremely slim
and it wasn't gonna happen then perhaps
he never would have stepped foot into
that River a fortified and enforced
border you know it may seem scary and
mean to metropolitan liberals but it
would be life-saving for people like
Ramirez and people on both sides of the
border if Ramirez knew that he could not
get here by erroneously seeking asylum
or he could and he could not get here by
sneaking across then he then then then
he'd be left with two options and both
would have saved his life one would be
to apply for citizenship through the
standard channels to stay in El Salvador
and try to find other ways to increase
your income either of those option you
know the either option is fine either of
them would have meant that he he and his
daughter alive today and there are a lot
of people there are a lot of people have
died trying to cross the border and
would not have
have they never attempted it and we
could encourage people or rather
discourage them from attempting it by
making it extremely extremely difficult
to do that is the compassionate choice I
think all right Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com is
the email address we'll get to a few
emails let's see this is from Tim says
Matt thank you for your continued hard
work engaging with many of the hard and
complex issues we face in society
yesterday you made a remarkable point
that I feel it needs more attention when
introducing a photo of the recent
tragedy at the border you said that it's
horrific for anyone to use the photo for
any lesser purpose especially to make a
political point this is so important for
us to consider in our culture today you
were then quick to expose the absurdity
of Democrats leveraging the lives and
deaths of a father and daughter to rally
harder against the Trump's
administration's border policy and
practices while I agree wholeheartedly
with this analysis I think it's vital
that you also condemn Trump's statement
in which he likewise uses the tragedy to
argue a different point and now quoting
Trump they want to have open borders and
open borders mean crime and open borders
mean people drowning in rivers I hate it
and I know that it could stop
immediately if the Democrats would
change the laws and then the father who
probably was this wonderful guy with his
daughter things like that wouldn't
happen I realized that keeping up with
Trump's tweets such nonsense is
impossible and there are plenty of
left-wing media folks trying to do that
for any reason but in this case it is
entirely irrelevant highly relevant to
your earlier point that no one should
try to profit off of the suffering of
others by using a photo like that for
political game this is yet another form
of human objectification our society is
completely normalized and we should
condemn all instances of it regardless
of whether we agree with the logic that
follows or the ends being sought thanks
again for the show hi Tim well I I mean
I agree with your basic point about not
using it and and and and I agree that it
is in a form of objectification of
dehumanization when we look at death and
whether it's a whether it's people that
have died crossing
border or it's a school shooting when we
see these bodies just as tools to be
used and it's it is very much
objectification we're turning them into
objects and we are not recognizing their
humanity anymore so I agree with that I
don't think that's what Trump was doing
any more than then then that's what I
was doing what I was doing just now and
yesterday on the show and what Trump was
doing I think was to clarify to explain
in the face of lies and distortions the
actual truth people are blaming those
deaths on Trump Trump is responding to
those accusations he didn't now I know
this sounds like a childish sort of they
started it sort of thing but I guess
that day that is what I'm saying you
know when Trump isn't the one who dug up
this photo it's at a see here no it was
it was the left took that photo we're
using it to bludgeon him and he's saying
no that's not no no look look if we're
gonna have this discussion then let's
talk about why that actually happened
it's hope out open borders and so on so
I think he's entitled to defend himself
and I think he also has a responsibility
as the president to to to offer
clarifications on things like this so I
in that case now look I don't think
Trump is above using tragedies for
political gain I think almost every
politician does it and I don't think
Trump is an exception but in this case I
don't think that's what he did when
someone comes to you with an accusation
and says hey you you caused this tragedy
I think you're allowed to say no same
thing with again with the school
shootings and when someone tries to use
that against Second Amendment advocates
I think the Second Amendment advocates
are entitled to respond no it's you're
wrong in fact you know the Second
Amendment would would would help prevent
these things all right this is from Sam
says love the show I always enjoy
listening to your show it's very
educational I am 15 and I go to an
all-boys Catholic
I've started to like girls and notice
girls more over this past year I have
friends who have started dating and some
of those relationships have been good
and some have not been good my friends
say I should wait to date girls until
I'm interested in getting married my
brother who's 20 and in college just got
his first girlfriend and says that I
should wait I was just wondering if you
have any thoughts on this topic or could
give me any advice hi Sam well great
question
maybe the first to tell you full
disclosure that I did not take the
advice that I am going to give you When
I was your age I did not take this
advice so I understand why people don't
take it because I didn't but I wish I
did and my advice well it's the same
advice that your brother and your and
your parents gave you I agree with them
we have to ask ourselves a simple
question what's the point of dating I
think Sam that's the question she asked
yourself like what I wanting to date is
a natural healthy thing to want but I
think you should just ask like what's
what is it what's the point of it
everything has a point not just dating
everything has a point if it's a thing
if it exists it has some kind of point
some kind of purpose so what's the point
if we say that the point is something
like well having fun or getting to know
someone I would say that's that's not
really a point it's sort of okay fun and
getting though something to what end and
now it's possible to have fun just for
the sake of having fun you go out and
play a pickup game of basketball the
main point is just it's fun for the sake
of fun it's it's an end in and of itself
which is fine for something like a game
but for a human relationship I don't
think the end itself can be fun I think
it's gotta be it's cuz it's it's
something deeper and more complex and
that's not a game right so plus you can
have fun with someone and get to know
them without dating them dating them is
a kind of weird thing where you actually
define the relationship and and the two
of you wreck it and that's why in every
dating relations as I was when I was
your age like I think people still do
this maybe they don't but back in the
old days if you were dating there had to
be that weird conversation at some point
where you establish that okay we're
boyfriend and girlfriend
and there's no non awkward way of doing
that it's always super awkward and but
the certain point you got to like
establish what we are now I think these
days people maybe never bother to define
it and they are they just that's why
people say it's not even dating anymore
just we're hanging out we're just we're
just hanging around the same vicinity as
each other which is which makes it even
worse when it's not defined but in the
traditional dating scenario it's defined
boyfriend-girlfriend okay so again
what's the point what's the point of
that distinction and besides as much as
we might say oh we're just having fun
it's not serious it will get serious
it always does dating relationships in
high school get very intense very
intense I mean you you you say things
like I love you you act totally
committed to each other devoted to each
other you become almost obsessed with
each other and all of that commitment
and devotion and suppose it has to be
headed somewhere it's not a switch you
can flip now it does feel like a switch
that sort of flipped on where all of the
sudden there is this intense infatuation
really is the word but it's not really a
switch that can be flipped off so it's
got to be headed somewhere you're in
this boat together where's the boat
going if you're both in your 20s and
you're at a high school then it could be
going to the altar to marriage and maybe
it doesn't ultimately but at least
there's that possibility and at least
there's an understanding that if all
things go according to plan that is the
the person that's where you're going
that's that's the end result that's the
end game and that gives you hope and
that gives you purpose and that makes it
worth it even if it doesn't work out you
could say then well it was still worth
it because I you know I I'm pursuing
marriage and I'm pursuing this next
phase of my life and I took a chance and
it didn't work out but but it was still
worth it was worth the chance because
the end is worth it
but the problem is that in high school
it's almost certain that it's not headed
there No
talking about marriage in high school
99.9% of all high school relationships
do not end in marriage I'm making us a
testing up but it's probably pretty
close to accurate so most just end and
the end in heartbreak and devastation
feelings of betrayal abandonment hatred
jealousy it's it's now I think as an
adult and I look back and I've been
married for eight years and I got you
know four kids now and so I can look
back to my relationships that I was in
as a teenager and I can sort of see it
as from this perspective now I can see
it as this kind of like silly thing and
it doesn't but at the time it was not
silly and and breakups were devastating
heartbreaking you know you because you
can't you can't see it it's like you
can't remove yourself from your own
perspective
which is yeah if someone might tell you
hey well look yeah you were dating that
person for six months sound like you
guys weren't married people get divorced
after being married for 15 years they
have kids I mean imagine how they feel
six months likely yeah well you can
recognize intellectually it's not the
same thing but that doesn't yeah but
that's not your life this is your life
and so it's a very hard thing for kids
to deal with so if marriage isn't on the
table and you get into a serious and
committed relationship with someone
you've just guaranteed yourself a messy
and heartbreaking split it's guaranteed
every day you spend with that person you
know in the back of your mind that
eventually probably in the next few
months you're gonna hate each other you
you know it's going there so all this
talk about love and commitment it's all
really a joke and you sort of know that
you don't mean for it to be a joke but
in the back of your mind you know you
say I love you I'm so committed but you
know it's like you know in 20 years
you're not gonna be with this person in
ten years you would probably in ten
months you won't so you're kind of lying
to each other and it's a game and it's
not a very nice or fair game to be
playing with another with another
person's heart quit playing games with
my heart that was now this is doesn't
before your time but very wise words
from I think the Backstreet Boys
some people will say that high school
relationships teach you things you learn
from them yeah you what do you learn
though you learn how to break up you
learn how to hate someone and used to
claim to love you learn how to say
things you don't mean to people that you
pretend to care about you learn a lot of
lessons that really aren't handy in a
marriage you learn how to be in a failed
relationship you learn how to get
divorced basically it's divorced
practice it's not marriage practice
there really isn't anything like
marriage practice marriage is one of
those things where you know you just you
learn how to do it when you're in it you
learn more just just like with a job
right I mean you could train for your
job learn about you'll learn more in the
first day of your job then you could
possibly learn in ten years of reading
books about it and you'll learn more on
your first day of marriage that you
could have ever learned through through
any dating relationship so that's my
that's what I would say is but as I said
I recognize that it you know we can all
say this because it's easy for us now to
say all this it would thought with our
hindsight and everything but when you're
actually in high school you know to
actually put that off until college or
after college it was a very difficult
thing to do but if you can if you can
pull that off I would say you won't
regret it and what I'll tell you now
I've been babbling for too long last
thing I'll say is I guarantee you that
when you're 25 or whatever and you're
married if you're married by then and
you didn't date in high school you
absolutely will not regret having not
dated you won't regret it
especially because
once you get married and you have kids
your past life it's like it's like
someone else's life it's like you hardly
it's like a blur all of a sudden you've
started this whole new life you're a new
person and so you're not gonna regret
that
all right let's leave it there thanks
for the questions and we'll talk
tomorrow
Godspeed and sayonara
by the way hola mamacita the first
Democratic presidential primary debate
was last night and everyone started
speaking Spanish we will examine while
US Democrats sohn muy estupido so then
my pal Jamil jivani stops by to explain
why young men get radicalized finally
the mailbag check it out on the Michael
Noel's show